you
hello folks good to see you all
when i announced in early december
at a goal that i set of administering
100 million shots for the virus
in the first 100 days of our office 100
million shots in 100 days
it was considered ambitious some even
suggested it was somewhat audacious
experts said that it was uh the plan was
quote definitely aggressive
and distribution would have to be
seamless
for us to be successful one headline
simply put it
quote it won't be easy end of quote
well it wasn't when i took office when
we took office
there was a lot that had to be done we
needed more vaccines
more vaccinators more places for people
to get
vaccinated and we needed a whole
government approach
so i directed jeff zeins the coordinator
of our covet 19 response
to put us on a war footing and i meant
that in a literal sense
to get us on track to truly beat this
virus
i'm proud to announce that tomorrow
58 days into our administration
we will have met my goal of ministering
100 million shots
to our fellow americans that's weeks
ahead of schedule
and even with the setbacks we face
during the winter storms
and there's another big step on the path
to checking
the putting checks in pockets and shots
in people's arms
when we crossed the 50 million doses
just three weeks ago
i told you that every time we hit the 50
million mark
i'd update you on our progress so here's
where we are today
eight weeks ago only eight percent of
seniors
those most vulnerable to cova 19 had
received a vaccination
today 65 percent
of people aged 65 or older have received
at least
one shot and 36 percent
are fully vaccinated and that's key
because this is the population that
represents 80 percent
of the well over 500 000 cova 19 deaths
that have occurred in america
we have nearly double the amount of
vaccine doses that we distribute to
states
tribes and territories each week we have
gone
from one million shots a day that i
promised in december
before we're even sworn in to an average
of two and one
half million shots a day outpacing the
rest of the world
significantly and here's how we
accomplish this
using the power given to a president
under the defense production act
we expedited critical materials in
vaccine production
such as equipment machinery and supplies
we work with vaccine manufacturers to
speed up the delivery of millions more
doses and brokered a historic
manufacturing partnership
between competing companies who put
patriotism on public health first
these steps put us on track to have
enough vaccine
enough vaccine supply for every adult
american
by the end of may months
months earlier than anyone expected
and we stood up or supplied more than
600
community vaccination sites that are
administering
hundreds of thousands of shots per day
we launched the federal pharmacy program
which has allowed
millions of americans to get a shot
at one of 1 000 or extremely one of 14
000 local pharmacies in this country
the same way they get their flu shot
and for folks who aren't near a pharmacy
or mass vaccination center
we've supplied more than 500 mobile
clinics
like pop-up sites or vans meeting
people where they are meeting people
where they are
we developed nearly we deployed nearly 6
000
federal personnel including fema
active duty military and department of
health and human services to support
vaccinations and serve as vaccinators
putting the needle in people's arms
we're also supplying vaccines to
community health centers
to reach those who have been the hardest
hit
the hardest hit and suffered the most
especially black latino native american
and rural communities
this is really important because we
believe that speed and efficiency must
be matched with
fairness and equity now when president
harris and i
took a virtual tour of a vaccination
center in arizona
not long ago one of the nurses
on that on that tour injecting people
giving vaccinations
said that each shot
was like administering a dose of hope
a dose of hope that's how she phrased it
behind these 100 million shots
are millions of lives changed when
people receive that dose of hope
grandparents can hug their grandchildren
again frontline workers
who can show up at their jobs without
the same fear they used to have
teachers with the confidence to head
back into the classroom
these milestones are significant
accomplishments
but we have much more to do
much more to do and the american rescue
plan will help us do it
in addition to the cash payments it
provides to you and your families it
also provides
the funds to add vaccinators to supply
more
community vaccinations support more
community vaccination centers
and increase testing it'll help us
accelerate
nationwide efforts to reopen our schools
safely
and as i told the nation last week i've
directed all states
tribes and territories to make all
adults eligibly vaccinated no later than
may
the first i'm glad to see that several
states are already taking that step
to make more and more americans eligible
even before
may 1st tomorrow we'll hit
100 million doses our administration has
administered
but i've always said that's just the
floor
we will not stop until we beat this
pandemic
next week i'll announce our next goal to
put
shots in arms this is a time for
optimism
but it's not a time for relaxation
i need all americans i need all of you
to do your part
wash your hands stay socially distanced
keep masking up as recommended by the
cdc
and get vaccinated when it's your turn
now is not the time to let down our
guard
in the last week we've seen increases in
the number of cases in several states
scientists have made clear that things
may get worse
as new variants of this virus spread
getting vaccinated is the best thing we
can do to fight back against these
variants
while millions of people are vaccinated
we need millions
more to be vaccinated and again
i need you to get vaccinated when it
comes to your term and you're able to do
that
i need your help i need you to help
not just the country but your family
your friends your neighbors
get them vaccinated as well if we keep
our guard up
stick together and stick with the
science
we can look forward to a fourth of july
that feels a bit more normal
with small groups able to gather for
cookouts in backyards
and when we be where we begin to declare
our independence
on independence day from the virus look
together
together we're going to come through
this stronger with renewed faith in each
other
and our government that fulfills this
most important function
protecting the american people let me be
clear again
wearing this mask in the meantime
making sure you wash your hands making
sure you socially distance
listen to the cdc we've got to reach the
point
where we have herd immunity meaning
where we have a vast
majority of the american people have
been vaccinated before we can stop
wearing these
so please please don't let what happens
you see happening in europe when you see
on television
keep the faith keep wearing the mask
keep washing your hands
and keep socially distance we're going
to beat this
we're way ahead of schedule but we've
got a long way to go
i just want to bring you up to date and
i thank you very much and
god bless america may god protect our
troops thank you so much
mr president vladimir putin wants open
talks would you agree to that
your reaction to the photo of children
in the border detention center